mais là c'est nouveau ça tu la fais
juste pour la robe ou ben non mais parce
que j'avais fait un petit moment parce
que j'aime bien chez 5 min j'adore qu'à
d'autres tatouages
oui oui la serbie ce tollé dans le coup
ensuite des ailes d'ange c'est la date
c'est la date de naissance de ma
grand-mère d'ailleurs que j'embrasse
elle s'est fait mal aux eaux
elle nous regarde je t'aime allez allez
donc à la dea en 1720 ribéry dont les
137 et va êre non non non et non et sur
qu'est steve bourricot new way ça ça ils
normes et m'en vais réagir est ce que ça
vous a choqué ou pas ici sur le flanc
alors énorme alors derrière je voulais
juste vous dire cette séquence à fait
normal a fait énormément réagir
notamment l'eau silva mais même si c'est
un poisson dans des jacuzzis un des
points ce soir honnêtement oui moi tout
ce qui touche aux animaux je suis j'en
ai deux je défend énormément la
fondation bardot
[Rires]
[Musique]
on dit des animaux mais c'est des
crustacés
les poissons et les crustacés des crabes
non mais peu importe pourquoi on serait
moins triste pour des poissons que pour
un mouton
je veux dire ce sont les animaux sont
des êtres vivants chose aux animaux je
suis pas bien et je défends 200 milles 1
mille ha ouais ouais mais ce qu'il dit
ils ont même pas de sens les poissons
patrice attend jamais à la fois comme
j'étais à cannes on m'a dit que ma robe
elle me faisait penser à elle mérité
[Rires]
d'ailleurs
oh les gars elle avait le paraguay mise
à l'encan paris c'est des belles
chanteuses mais reina exactement je le
connaissais pas du tout et l'exercice
est arrivé comme ça il m'a dit d'imiter
donc avec naulleau qui est un livreur
[Rires]
j'adore de l'encenser
mais j'adore pour le mieux en fait
j'avais décrit nuages mais également été
deux cannibales à trois trios hb et e
qu'est-ce que vous avez n'est pas des
gros sous 5000 euros la route s'arrêter
car moi je prends la route je vais
acheter un appart à poil y a la taille
de keddy la robe faisait juste deux
cents us c'était 200 boulin